bonsoir à tous je suis ravi d'être là
alors je vais vous parler gourmandie je
vous parlait d'amour avec mes mots à moi
mes mots à moi c'est je suis amoureux de
gourmandise je suis gourmand et comment
aller de cet amour de la gourmandise à
la gourmandise de l'amour vous avez
compris que ce soir je sors de ma zone
de confort tant que je moi je fais des
gâteaux je fais des gâteaux et en fait
ce qui me manque c'est un fou et ça va
être une table ça va être une poche ça
va être tout ce qui m'entoure tous les
jours et qui me rassure en fait ce que
j'ai choisi de faire et non pas de
parler devant des gens mais si je peux
partager en fait cet amour de la
gourmandise et pour les emmener vers
cette gourmandise de l'amour ben
j'espère que je vais réussir au moins un
tout petit peu alors pour commencer je
vais vous inviter à partager une
expérience gastronomique gustatives
peut-être à la fin on va aller vers une
méditation gourmande
donc voyez mais de ceux qui entendent
pas vraiment dans le fond j'espère que
vous aurez au moins une partie du
discours
alors vous avez dans vos sachets un tout
petit sachet
avec deux bonbons de chocolat
et donc je vais sur tony touch est pas
encore donc je vous demande d'ouvrir le
sachet peut-être mais ne touchez pas
encore je vais vous donner des clés en
fait pour le déguster au mieux ce sont
mes clés à moi on va goûter avec les
cinq sens et après vous goûterez avec
vos clés à vous et je vous ai préparé un
petit comment il ya un titre une
suggestion d'accompagnement une
suggestion d'accompagnement qui j'espère
vous plaire donc on va déguster ce
bonbon chocolat ce que je vais essayer
de vous faire fondre
alors attention vous allez le tenir vous
allez voir ça font donc ce coeur qu'on
va d'abord commencer par regarder
donc vous voyez sa couleur c'est
vraiment très intense et ça me fait
penser ça vous fait penser certains
aussi à ces variétés de cerises vous
savez coeur de pigeons donc j'ai
vraiment rouge intense parce que j'aime
les j'aime les couleurs et et est en
fait la première chose qu'on fait c'est
qu'on voit qu'on garde
est-ce que ça me plaît ça ne me plaît
pas ensuite vous avez toujours ne
touchez pas ne mangez pas encore
ensuite vous allez prendre en main
deuxième sens le toucher
vous allez voir que il fait assez chaud
ce soir ça va fondre assez rapidement là
c'est du chocolat c'est tout à fait
normal donc là aussi vous allez avoir
des indications 15 c'est assez gras
c'est riche sa faune dans la main c'est
un coeur ils font c'est tout à fait
normal
ensuite je vous demanderai de croquer
donc la cellule où il va intervenir mais
là vous n'entendrez certainement rien ou
si vous entendrez le silence parce que
surtout ne mangeait pas encore ne mangez
pas encore
j'en vois qui prennent déjà le coeur en
bouche et je les ai déjà dit trois fois
ne mangeait pas encore d'où la
difficulté est apte en adac ormandy vous
voyez c'était donc vous croquez la
moitié donc écouter vous n'entendrez
rien sur un autre beau mon chocolat qui
sera un peu frais très riche en cacao
bas ça fera un joli petit clic puis sera
riche en cacao plus le son sera et vue
et puis sera froid aussi plus le son
sera francs donc on se sert aussi des
comme quand on goûte un croissant vous
avez ça chante ça frétille c'est
magnifique
donc ensuite l'autre moitié j'aimerais
pour la porter ou non c'est à dire pour
sentir bon pour faire intervenir votre
odorat vraiment sentir ce qui est à dire
les arômes les arums qu'on perçoit à
travers le nez là vous aurez des notes
de vanille vous aurez des notes de l'est
c'est quelque chose de très près de vous
avez deux notes de framboise parce que
il ya intérieur une ganache à la
framboise
donc c'est vraiment quelque chose
d'assez élégant d'assekrem eux on n'est
pas dans les caractérise d'un chocolat
puissant on est vraiment dans la douce
ce soir on parle d'amour on parle de
gourmandises dont on est dans la douceur
et enfin le goût bah je vous demanderais
effectivement de bien mâcher de bien
laisser fondre à la fois cette coque de
shakala à la fois cette ganache à la
framboise
il ya un soupçon d'eau-de-vie de
framboise qui me permet de relever un
peu le tout c'est une ganache chocolat
noir et vous aurez un équilibre aussi de
puissance toute cette soirée je vais
parler un peu d' équilibre de puissance
donc il faut que tout soit équilibré
c'est à dire qu'on sente un peu la vanne
nico sentent le lait qu'on sente
également la framboise et puis
je vais vous demander de vous concentrer
sur l'arrière goût aussi le goût que va
laisser ce moment chocolat en bouche
quand vous l'aurez déguster et ceci
pendant tous pratiquement mon discours
donc laisser venir tout ce qui va se
révéler et pour ça je le dis tout
d'abord je vais préparer une petite
surprise parce que je vous ai ramené un
tableau donc que vous allez pouvoir
regarder parce que si je parle quand
scrutin je pense au gâteau quand je fais
des gâteaux je pense à la peinture je
fais un peu de tout en même temps mais
je fais ce que j'aime et donc je vous
demanderai de rentrer dans cette toile
si vous en avez envie ou de fermer les
yeux tout simplement on voit une petite
musique alors une musique assez facile
vous allez voir ça va être très crémeux
savez trés viennois et laissez vous
aller à cette petite méditation
gourmande
vous pouvez manger
m
et
nous
voilà bah écoutez moi j'en ai encore
plein la bouche tu vois que ça s'entend
donc vous avez pu remarquer aussi que on
est dans une ambiance un peu chaudes
dont vous avez une sensation sucrée un
peu plus importante
donc on est vraiment là dans le sucre on
est on est dans la douceur on est soyeux
on écrème eux on est vraiment entouré de
deux de volupté de gmc j'aime ces
moments où tout particulièrement alors
moi moi je mens à cordes plein comme ça
je vais à sortir par exemple un chemin
un chocolat beaucoup plus amer avec une
musique qui va bien avec peut-être une
un verre de whisky qui va bien avec même
un petit cigare
je peux le faire tout seul ou c'est les
moments qui peuvent être partagés entre
amis également
donc tout ça pour créer des moments
d'émotion unique que je fais appel à
tous les sens et où je vais vié tout le
reste
en fait je peux avoir de l'amour pour
moi même ou pour les gens qui ont fait
ces différents que ça soit au whisky que
ce soit un bon cigare s'il est bien fait
on va vers la perfection et on va à
sortir tous ces éléments de qualité
identique pour créer un moment en fait
de d'exception pour soi ou à partager
alors maintenant vous l'aurez compris
j'ai ramené une veste et je vais mettre
cette veste je vais vous emmener dans
mon atelier et je vais vous expliquer
comment je fais des gâteaux parce que
moi je fais des gâteaux et des chocolats
ont tout de suite quand je mets cette
laisse je me sens un peu plus à l'aise
alors comment je fais mes gâteaux ou
l'aurez compris
mon univers et visuelle j'aime la beauté
j'aime ce qui est chatoyant j'aime les
couleurs j'aime l'opposition des
couleurs j'aime tout particulièrement
quand ça ap est à la fois en bouche
visuellement et de départ d'un gâteau
c'est toujours une image une vision
quelque chose que j'ai à voir dans la
nature une feuille une sculpture jeu
je fais une expo et puis voilà je vois
une toile qui masque bien je visite
infuse et puis voilà je retiens une
forme je retiens quelque chose il tient
ça va faire un gâteau
j'ai par exemple eu l'occasion de goûter
un cocktail dans une boîte de nuit
chicago et dans le fond de mon cocktail
j'avais une fleur d'hibiscus confites
je suis trouvé ça extraordinaire et j'en
ai fait un gâteau d'une boîte de nuit
chicago est aussi ça peut être dans les
vosges avec une très belle feuille d'une
certaine manière qui va me donner l'idée
de d'un certain 9,2 pas que je vais
travailler en chocolat donc pour moi la
vision est essentiel la vue ensuite
comment est ce que je fais en fait
comment est ce que je vais architecture
et le futur est architecturé ce gâteau
dont je vais me servir de mes cinq sens
on les a énumérés tout à l'heure c'est
vraiment très important pour moi et je
vais architecture et ce gâteau
je repars comme un architecte pourrait
construire une maison fondation bâti toi
quelque chose qui tienne quand vous le
coupez que ça ne tombe pas avec les
structures les plus denses dans le fond
si je vais prendre un feuilleton intra
line est un peu gros quand un peu rigide
ou une pâte sablée parfaitement cuite
donc ça c'est par exemple une tarte
crème vanille avec de l'églantine c'est
simple mais c'est bon
donc cette architecture en fête du goût
des saveurs des structures c'est
toujours quelque chose de très risqué
parce que c'est un équilibre alors
souvent je trouve facilement où je suis
sur mes deux pieds sans problème ou des
fois je suis sur le fil ou l' équilibre
est très fragile où je joue avec des
choses très très fine ou des fois c'est
risqué mais lorsque j'ai la vision en
fait de ce gâteau que j'imaginais et que
les saveurs s'équilibre parce que les
saveurs doivent s'équilibrer
on doit toujours sans dire d'un gâteau
les textures aussi lui ne doit pas
écraser l'autre
donc après j'y arrive comment moi
j'essaie d'atteindre la perfection
je dis bien j'essaye de tendre vers la
perfection
c'est ce qui me motive en fait ce qui me
motive c'est le beau geste c'est quand
je fais une tarte
j'aime bien que le fonds soit
parfaitement foncé comme on dit dans
notre jargon après que la cuisson soit
parfaitement réalisé c'est à dire un peu
plus que la moyenne
parce que j'aime ce soit croustillant
très croustillant très croquant et vous
savez que ce côté un peu torréfaction de
la farine aura jusqu'à la caramélisation
de la farine c'est comme ça que j'aime
donc tendre vers une certaine perfection
à la fois dans la réalisation dans
l'aboutissement dans le geste parce
qu'un geste qui est beau et très souvent
efficace vous pouvez le vérifier dans
tous les domaines si on prend les
sportifs les sportifs qui vont très vite
quand ce sont des courses
bah ils ont des gestes qui sont parfaits
qu'ils sont beaux et qui sont élégants
quand sébastien loeb passe une courbe en
fait il le fait à la perfection lit mais
la voiture exactement dans le bon angle
pour passer au plus vite
et ces boues et si vous regarder à la
télé c'est ce qu'il ya plus fluide
c'est pour ça qu'il va plus vite ton
geste et efficace et dans mon domaine
j'ai eu l'occasion de travailler chez
quelqu'un à le démettre et rentrant dans
le laboratoire en fait il y avait une
pancarte et sur laquelle il y avait
écrit l'artisan est un homme libre et sa
liberté rendit dans l'imperfection
on parle de liberté on parle de
perfection et naturellement de travail
mais tendre vers cette perfection moi
c'est ce qui me passionne et donc vous
voyez ça c'est qu'une pâte feuilletée en
fait mais je trouve ça beau on n'a pas
souvent là l'habitude de la trouver
comme ça mais il ya du mouvement cet
élégant et c'est tout simplement beau
c'est ce que j'ai donc maintenant
comment est ce qu'on arrive à cette
gourmandise de l'amour que j'aime tant
toujours dans mon métier
lorsque je suis arrivé à paris c'est
dans les années 80 une des premières
maisons que j'ai fait c'était la maison
dalloyau et j'ai eu l'occasion de
l'intégrer le poste d entre eux mais
c'est là où on fait des gâteaux et mon
deuxième jour le reste le responsable d
entre eux mêmes le dima me confie une
recette tout à fait classique limoux
donne la marche à suivre et à la fin de
ces explications les me dit et fais le
avec amour fais le avec un bon c'est une
notion que j'avais jusqu'à présent
jamais entendu dans mon métier
hier personne ne l'avait jamais dit et
ça va vraiment parler mais ça ne sert
toujours ça me sert au quotidien
mais j'aime ça donc
faire chaque ges le faire avec amour
il m'est arrivé d'aller manger chez
antoine westermann quand il venait
d'avoir ses trois étoiles table
fabuleuse et à la fin de son service
saillie passe à table et il me voit et
bien thierry pourquoi tu m'as pas dit
que tu étais là parce que j'aime savoir
pour qui je cuisine j'aime savoir pour
qui je cuisine donc cette dose d'amour
qui met dans ses plats c'est fabuleux et
on le ressent essayer de faire une table
d'une grande table par an c'est fabuleux
pour goûter à cette grande cuisine à ce
que ces gens mettent en oeuvre à cet
amour qui met dans les plats pour les
partager avec des gens qui viennent
pareil comme ma grand mère qui alors
tout le monde parle de sa grand-mère
moma grand mâle alpha déconfiture le
souvenir que j'en ai c'est plus de
l'amour qu'elle mettait dans sa
confiture côte sa confiture
parce que sa confiture quand elle monte
un pouls de la cave en fait souvent
c'était plutôt une confiture très très
cuite ça tenait parce que c'était réduit
c'était plus caramélisées que que le
goût du fruit
et puis si tout allait bien il n'y avait
pas de moisissures dessus mais des fois
ça arrive et ça arrivait souvent qu'ils
avaient connu la guerre et puis ben elle
enlevait en fait le petit film et puis
avec la cuillère il ya un peu de
moisissures dessus mais c'est pas grave
tout ça tu peux manger quand même je
relève la moisissure et tu verras c'est
très bon et je mange je m'en souviens
encore pas de la confiture parce
qu'aujourd'hui je sais faire mieux un
moment fait mieux mais le souvenir j'en
ai c'est l'amour qu'elle mettait dans sa
confiture l'amour qu'elle mettait à à
faire plaisir aux autres et j'en viens
au partage en fait donc quand je réalise
en fait d'aider des cathos c'est pour
les partager
j'aime les partager avec d'autres j'aime
qui se régalent et les gens qui viennent
à nos ânes au cours de pâtisserie ou six
élèves la mode en ce moment à ce point
avec ses cours de cuisine et de
gastronomie c'est parce que les gens
apprennent à faire pour eux mêmes parce
qu'ils passent un bon moment déjà
ils font pour eux mêmes y réalise
quelque chose et surtout après ils font
pour d'autres une dame m'a dit un jour à
qu'est-ce que j'ai eu comme succès avec
votre 7,2 financiers qu'est-ce que j'ai
eu comme succès avec votre recette
donc elle a reçu de l'amour grâce à sa
recette de financiers donc c'est
fabuleux et tout ça pour quoi
bah pour rendre ce monde un peu meilleur
moi je fais juste des gâteaux je ne
sauve pas des vies
je construis pas de ponts mais un gâteau
à partager ce savoir transmis que
d'autres également peuvent transmettre
ou peuvent faire pour d'autres c'est la
richesse c'est de l'amour c'est d'amour
en baron peu à dire et je vous souhaite
ce soir de devenir comme moi des
gourmands d'amour à votre façon avec
vous sensibilité avec vos préférences et
met cette dose d'amour chez eux avec un
monde dans tout ce que vous réalisez
peut-être à l'image d'une tarte comme
celle ci breil à nantes qui représente
la lumière le soleil une certaine
douceur une certaine pureté
elle est aussi parsemé de poivre de
sarah break d'un côté épicé
des fois quand je suis content de ce que
j'ai réalisé je me dis ouah c'est bon
c'est bon et maintenant pour finir vous
avez encore un petit chocolat dans un
sachet alors vous pouvez le goûter
maintenant et maintenant où vous le
goûter dans une heure ou le goûter
demain choisissez le moment ça va être
une ganache au gingembre avec un
chocolat de couverture 61%
ça sera beaucoup plus long en bouche ça
sera beaucoup plus intense d'un point de
vue informatique et ça sera zorées à
l'arrière-goût qui durera bien un quart
d'heure donc vous pensez encore
peut-être pas moins dans un quart
d'heure je vous remercie et je vous
souhaite une excellente soirée